hey hello
good to see you all hope you're feeling
good
it is wednesday at seven
ashley culture nathaniel atfield
get your videos on get your videos on
what is it good to see you aaron
good to see you great folks what a
wonderful time to be alive
[Music]
you might have to run out halfway
through this call maybe maybe
no maybe so here here we are all right
if you uh hello it's good to see you
um if you guys could mute your mics
and then i'm going to give you a bit of
intros to what's going to happen this
evening
so get your likes muted
and uh i'll give you i'll give you a
little bit of what's going to happen
so it is now 8 o'clock so we're going to
officially start
i thought i'd start the start the
evening
with an introduction from steve from
benchmark mortgages
um just if anyone doesn't know who steve
is
steve is a mortgage broker he also
provides bridging finance
um so we introduce all of our clients to
steve i use steve myself and it's
absolutely fabulous
um so i'm gonna get steve to talk for a
few minutes
about bridging finance and mortgages and
what's happening at the moment
and then i'm going to open it up if
anyone's got any questions
or if you've got a uh a success
or anything you want to share at all i'm
going to open it up to the board for
people to just jump in
so while steve's talking if everyone
could make sure that your mic is muted
um
that would be really really really
helpful but steve are you live
can you hear me yeah you're loud and
clear you can hear me
excellent i can indeed say steve it'd be
great if you could give a little update
as to what's happening by the way great
to see so many familiar faces on the
call
i can see gemma edens uh mentor anthony
wilmott
um stefano debbie willis absolutely
loads of familiar faces so you know
first i just want to say
thank you guys for being on the call
we're gonna have an absolutely
incredible
evening today the next hour's gonna be
compact so get ready to participate
take notes ask questions uh steve
great to have a little update on what's
happening with mortgages so over to you
okay guys i'm steve i'm a property
investor and a mortgage and bridging
broker
so i'm on the samuel 365 mentoring calls
i noticed i'm getting
a few of the same kind of calls i
thought i'd address something that kind
of covers everybody
but maybe more for some of the newbies
this week um it's to do
with making yourself mortgageable
okay so as a new investor there's a few
things that you can do to make yourself
more mortgageable
the first thing is keep your eye on your
credit score
so if you've not already been on
experian and paid for the free 30 days
do that find out if you've got anything
that's
holding you back and address it and make
sure that you always pay more
than the minimum on your credit card
make sure you're on the electoral roll
all these things will boost your credit
score and make you more mortgageable
okay um another thing you can do to take
care of your credit is
don't get too many decision principles
done every time you have one done
it gives you a soft footprint some do a
hard footprint
so if you really need one to view a
property they're insisting on it
of course get one done but don't get
them done willy nilly
it's not great for your credit okay so
not too many unless you really need them
so if you're a first-time buyer or a
first-time landlord it's a little bit
different
if you're a first-time buyer going for a
buy to let it's very hard to get by to
let
hmo mortgages but normal single let's
that can be done providers you've got
two things
you've got the deposit and you're in
work and if you're self-employed
you need to be self-employed for at
least a year for the year's book stamped
by an accountant
or if you're employed you need three
consistent pay slips
and you know something close to a
permanent contract
now if it's your first time by and
you're a first-time landlord
you're gonna be restricted how much you
can borrow based on your income
so if you earn twenty five thousand
pound a year they might lend you
somewhere between 100 and 125
and no matter what if it's buy to let in
your first time buy or your tenth house
you'll always need 25 percent deposit
okay once you're a homeowner so
you're not a first time buyer anymore
your own you own your own home
so it's not your first time buy but you
are a first-time landlord then it's much
easier to get
more choice of um buy to let mortgages
and you can also get hmo mortgage up to
six bedrooms
provided you're in work and your own
your own home
i'm not going to go on for too much
longer about this i try and keep it to
five minutes
i just wanted to give you a brief
overview especially for the newbies what
the musts are
must be in work must look after your
credit um
must have a deposit and if you haven't
done it on your own home
it can be done by toulette but if you
want hmo you need to really be a
homeowner or
be on a jv with somebody that is
that's great that's really really
helpful steve does anyone have any
questions
for steve right now if you do jump on
mortgage related go for it
hi steve uh this is dinesh hi how are
you doing
yeah good thank you um you know the
in one of the courses um there is a
mention about bridge to let
mortgages uh sorry lending that is you
get a bridge loan
yeah that get converted into your
mortgage at the end of the
um renovation period is that available
yeah it's a product that a few a few
lenders will do
and i'll just tell you quickly what i
think the pros and cons are
bridge to that bridge to that is great
if you've got a property where you want
assurance you're going to get a mortgage
at the end of it
okay so the same company going to give
you the bridge and the same company are
going to give you the mortgage
and there's nothing wrong with that but
here's the downfall
you are going to have that one company's
rates for bridging and you've got that
company's one rate for a mortgage
when you do them individually you've got
the choice of all the bridges who are
willing to bridge on that loan
so there might be more competitive
quotes and you've got the choice of all
the lenders who are going to refinance
it
which could save you quite a bit of
money in the long run for the sake of
doing two deals
so of course if someone came to me i'd
consider both and see what's the most
suitable product
but if as an investor the reason i would
use butcher that
would be if i was worried about getting
a mortgage on the back end of it it was
a property where i had some kind of
doubts
because even though it's a great product
it might be the best sometimes
it's not always the most financially
beneficial to you because you're not
getting the choice of all the other
lenders in the mix
thank you steve um i was told that 80
percent hmo mortgages are back have you
heard anything
i spoke someone today i mean that he
does a lot of hmos
they pop up from time to time at one
time two years ago there's a 15
deposit um this is what normally happens
with these things
they pop up for a while they use they
use them all up and they go away
secondly they come with higher interest
so when 15
mortgages were around the interest rate
was about 4.9 percent on those
so that's probably you know one to one
and a half percent higher
than a 25 deposit so for you it's what's
more important
a are you eligible for that mortgage
because it's probably just one lender or
two lenders that are offering it out of
all the ones that are out there
so do you fit their criteria secondly is
that the right move for you
you know because okay less money in but
you're going to pay more out so it's
it's assessing the option on the day i
think yeah thanks
for steve mortgages and then we're going
to move topics however
hold on hold on hold on however just to
say if anybody
wants to speak to steve outside of this
call you can book a one-on-one call with
steve at any time i'll talk about how to
do that in a moment
so last question for steve and then i'm
gonna shift um
i'm gonna shift topic so kabir go ahead
my friend is it possible to buy
a personal home under a company
okay it's not impossible
to do that however whenever you buy a
property in a company
it instantly would expose you to the
additional rate of stamp duty
so if you're a first-time buyer you're
going to miss out on all that stamp duty
benefit so it's something you'd have to
probably speak to
a property solicitor about to see if
it's the right decision for you
um i wouldn't say it's impossible but it
certainly isn't common
there would be a business reason for
that normally there'd normally be a
business reason for that
come here does that help yeah yeah thank
you steve
best way to get in touch with you if
anyone wants to talk mortgages so if
anyone wants to
get a mortgage yeah sure i'm going to
drop my details in the chat
and also i'm on the 365 mentoring right
at the bottom under mortgages
you can book a call me whenever you want
you know all the times are up there
i'm going to dive off the call shortly
because i'm moving house tomorrow so um
yeah if you need me i'll drop my details
in the box
and 365 on samuel's platform you can
book me on there boom
awesome stuff i wanted to get anthony
wilmar up as well because i can see him
i can see him
um i can see him on the call anthony
what's good brother
hey man how's it going yeah really well
i just i just
thought i'd get some pearls of wisdom
from you this week i know you've been
having
your social media right now is going
crazy with your deals that you're doing
i mean honestly
um massive respect i'm even jealous of
how many
deals you've got going through at the
moment so give us a load on what's
happening what you've been up to this
week
um so we've been pushing forward a lot
with the developments of the minute
um focusing on trying to find commercial
residential and land deals
and you know we've been we've been
pushing this quite a while
we've got a couple that we've had in the
pipeline and you know the headaches
we've had with dorm trying to get them
over the line and
you know um we we we secured a pub
conversion
in august 2019 um and we still haven't
completed on it and and
you know actually it's all starting to
come around now everything's settling
down and we actually had
confirmation today we signed all the
paperwork we've got a completion date
imminent so that's super exciting we've
got a a huge commercial to residential
project that we've just completed on
last week as well which
um you're hopefully coming to see which
i'm looking forward to
and um and i think the thing is you know
any strategy out there that people are
doing
is about persistence you know when we
when i speak to you guys on the
mentoring calls we're out there doing it
as well you know all the training that
samuel does we're implementing it
and you know it's about this the biggest
the biggest pearls of wisdom is really
about that's net networking aspect
and we say all the time network network
network you know tell
everyone you're a property investor
because you don't know who you're going
to meet
and be honest because i meet so many
people who lie about their journey and
lie about what they're doing
and it gets them nowhere you know and
i'll give you two huge examples of this
so
um example number one is lawton lawton's
on this call
you know law secured an amazing
development deal at the minute because
you know the person he went to see he
was honest about where he was up to on
his journey
you know he's built a great rapport with
this person and because of that
you know this guy wants to help him out
you know and he secured some amazing
deals through this through this
networking aspect
um you know i i happen to have a similar
situation this week where
i found the plot of land contacted the
agent and to say i wanted to secure this
particular deal
the agent come back to me and said it's
actually being sold through this company
i'll get them to contact you
and the guy that phoned me um you know
he he was really nice and he started
talking about
um started started grilling me you know
how many deals have you done you know
what kind of things are you up to at the
minute
and um for a reverse moment i was a bit
on the back foot but then when i started
to explain to him said look this is
where i'm up to this is who
i'm working with this is what i've done
in terms of training this is where i'm
up to
and he's like okay great super he said
the reason i'm asking this question is
because
you know i'm doing 170 million pound
development in liverpool at the minute
and i want to give you an opportunity
right now i've got deals like this
all over the uk it's too small for me
i'll put the land up
you develop it and then if it works this
is the start of a great relationship
and it all come from you know he saw
something in us
he saw something in the fact that you
know i was honest about two years ago
or three years ago i was still in a
retail job you know now i'm here
you know and everybody has to start
somewhere and he's obviously
and it's he's doing amazing deals and
he's clearly seen that so
the power of networking is huge you know
and and this is why we say document your
journey and network and
and tell people what you're doing
because you never know who's around the
corner
real brill braille and i want to add to
what anthony said actually really
importantly about
um about being honest and authentic with
where you're at
because then that's really really really
important but before i do that anthony
talk to me about perseverance and
systems because
you started this game a few years back
now and i think it must have been about
two and a half maybe three years ago
when you joined the academy
and i know that you got some quick
results you did
you did get results and you did deal
selling you got some joint ventures some
brr's you got somewhere to rent
but some of the bigger deals that you've
done have
as you've just said like taken forever
i wonder number one why have those deals
taken so long
and number two how did you have the
what can you teach us about perseverance
or some lessons
from that that would be really helpful
yeah definitely and
i think this comes back to and i always
dwell on this i always dwell on
you know when i first came to the dfe
one of the first things you said to me i
had this great idea for this
for what i wanted to do in terms of i
wanted to do biorefurbishing finance buy
all these houses refurb and refinance
them and build a huge portfolio
but at the time i wasn't making any
money and one of the things you said to
me was you know
yes do that's a great strategy build a
great portfolio
but you need to think about how are you
going to pay yourself month in month out
stop chasing you know the big things you
know this is about it's a pyramid build
your foundation first
and then start to scale above it so you
know so i did i went back to that
started to do the smaller strategies
like deal selling rent to rent
and then now when i started to focus on
the bigger stuff you know
it's it's balancing that scales i built
the foundations of buy to let's
rent to rent deal sourcing so it pays
the bills it keeps keeps
all the money coming in then i can look
at something big
as well and and start to try and focus
on that but i'm not putting
all my eggs into that one basket of one
big deal that i'm expecting is going to
pay me
50 60 grand just like that because it
doesn't happen
i'm still making the money through deal
source and i'm still focusing on smaller
things because that brings in the income
now
to pay me now which allows me to then
focus on the bigger things
and like i said some of the bigger deals
that we've done we've got two in
particular that have taken
they've taken over 13 months to complete
which is a long
time you know and um they've cost us
money so we've put money into them
already
and you need to you need to when you're
looking at things like development so
you're looking at these kind of deals
they're not a get-rich-quick scheme they
are a long-term game they are a
long-term plan
and you've got to think about if you're
getting into one of these projects or
you're going to
try and source one of these projects for
somebody it's not a quick payout because
there's lots of things you've got to
think about you've got to think about
the planning aspect of it if it needs it
you've got to think about the
conveyancing
if you're looking to do joint ventures
we spent a month just putting together
our joint venture
contract for this deal because it takes
so long to go backwards and forwards
from the solicitors and make sure that
all the parties are happy
so you've when you get into these you've
gotta
discipline your disappointments and be
prepared for it to be a long game
because if you don't then you can you
are gonna be disappointed very quickly
and you run the risk of losing a lot of
money
yeah that's so true and it's funny and
he's talking about disappointments and
stuff now but he's just completed on
some crazy big projects so
you know this is this is he's been real
about the journey and how long it took
but also you know
massive congratulations it's important
to discipline your disappointment but
also to celebrate your success
let's give anthony a hand isn't he
incredible um a couple of points i
wanted to kind of add on to what anthony
said is
and i said this to honestly a few years
ago when he first started is that you
want
fast pound and slow pound together so
you want to be doing strategies where
you're getting
fast pounds ie packaging and selling
deals
rent to rent you want to be getting
quick cash but then you also want to be
doing strategies as well
which are slow pounds now this is
passive and this is active you want the
two going on together
um and and and and with completing on a
property
it can take time but you've got what
you've got to remember is when the ball
is in your court
i.e the solicitor tells you to sign
something or whatever
you want to knock it out your court real
quick but when the ball
is not in your court and things are
taking a while you've got to be patient
you've got to be patient i'm a very
impatient person but i've learned that
this
this property game has taught me to be
patient and then one more thing i want
to say about auntie said which thought
was brilliant
is about being real with where you're at
i had a very similar situation anthony
last night last night i was on i was on
a zoom call with a guy who's got a
a pub and i know the pub really well
it's run down and i was trying to i was
trying to buy this pop off him right
and i was negotiating with him and i was
i was trying to
twist the knife a little bit because the
pub was run down
and i said to him i seen the bad press
on on your pub
you know the disgraced pub owner leaves
their
sorry it was bad like you must be
feeling pretty bummed out about this pub
so i'm like trying to dig the knife in a
little bit trying to get a good deal on
this tub
and um and and i said to him i said look
i don't think there's
loads of profit in this deal but i
reckon that
if we do a joint venture on the deal and
if you
want to get maybe a percentage of the
profits i'll pay you what you paid for
the pub
but i'll pay you when i've completed on
it and when i've demolished it and built
a house in it i said i don't think
there's loads of profit in this deal but
i do think that if it's done properly
and if it's done with expert you know if
it's done by experts from that i said
there's no one better in the game than
me we can make this work
this guy i'm talking to is a big
developer
i didn't know it right he he's got
like last year he's completed 200
million he's rich he's a lot richer than
i am
so i'm talking to him saying oh you need
an expert to come in and help you do
this
he's more successful than i am he's more
experienced than i am he's been in the
game longer than i am
right so i'm talking to him like i'm
some big expert and developing guy
and like he doesn't know what he's doing
he's insulted now
right so he's he he comes back at me
right he's any any and he says
he goes actually you know what we could
make this profitable as well but to be
honest this is small thrive for us
because we're working on this hundred
million development
this 50 million development like we
haven't got time to mess around with
this
so i immediately in mid-air quickly
change strategy
so rather than now rather i just
couldn't change strategy and
and i turned it to listen you're i
repeat what he told me about himself
i repeated everything back to and you
had heard him i'm like look
you're dealing with this 100 million
development and this 50 million
development
you haven't got time this is small fry
to you right i get that i said so the
thing is
we might only make half a million on
this for me that's the kind of that's my
bread and butter
and what you need is you need you need
someone who's going to put the time
and the effort into making this deal
work um
for you it's small fry you haven't got
the time but i'll do it i'll put the
time in and then we'll split the profits
how does that sound
and now it's it's you know it's looking
i'd say it's like 80 we're gonna get it
which is which is which is exciting i
know the deal really well it's a little
pub near where i used to live
um you know back in the midlands so you
know really important but again to just
be real where you're at like i could
have tried to play
play the big i am and when he when he
was like whoa he could have got into a
battle
or or or yeah and and anthony says it
just
honestly tells people look three years
ago i was in retail
you know this is where this is where i'm
at
and you're going to be ahead of some
people behind some people doesn't matter
i was speaking to a lady today actually
she was called i think her name was um
um fabian i think i think she might even
be on the court if you are fabu you can
jump up
my family said to me she goes i'm trying
to get my first rent to rent
but people keep saying to me have you
got a rent to rent already
can you show me your testimonial what
experience have you got i said fabio i
said that's a good thing
i said don't try and bluff and pretend
you've done it like anthony says what
you want to do is you want to
say hey you know what this will be my
first deal
and that's why i'm offering you such a
great attractive deal
because i really want to get a
testimonial from you throughout this
and because my first deal i'm gonna make
sure that i put all the
love and attention and care and this
deal to making sure it works
how does that sound would you like to do
business you know so you just
lean into where you're at own where
you're at
so you know that's just a few words of
advice from me anthony you're a rock
star
um i'm going to call on a few people i'm
going to get a few people i've got a few
people
i've seen the faces of i've been
chatting with but i'm going to pull some
people in
um she wants to say something dinesh go
ahead my brother
yes yes samuel um anthony mentioned
about the importance of networking
um and because we don't have physical
interaction during the course or dsm or
brr master process
i was just wondering we have the 365
community here if you can add
everybody into a whatsapp group we have
a small whatsapp group for the
members see if we can add all those
power group
the networking on the lights on the led
button how do you is it okay
i'm behind you sorry yeah
listen i'll put that to the team i don't
deal with that side of things
i'll put it to the team obviously you
guys i know you guys connect to network
and do things outside of
the official meets which is wonderful
and great um
in terms of having an official an
official one i'll put it to the team
ganesh but thank you for your suggestion
thank you awesome rockstar rockstar all
right
i wanted to get up um i wanted to jump
on gemma
gemma edens because i spoke to her
yesterday um so let me unmute you gemma
she acts all shy but she's not shy she's
a rock star
gemma what's good hey okay
good super good you've been having a
good few weeks since you got made
redundant
yeah just uh quite busy few weeks but
yeah
so tell us what have you done so far in
the last six weeks
um so it's amazing how much you can get
done when you're you know you're doing
it and you're going at it every day
um but in the last few weeks i
have done a hmo conversion deal
and i co-sourced um with
uh with ashley and ellen and jay who i
think are on this call
another hmo in liverpool um and i've
just done a br
yesterday um so all of those are going
through finance
and um i've just secured a portfolio of
10 properties from a landlord director
vendor
so um in total i've done about 16
000. when you first joined
samuel 365 i remember saying to you i'm
on a chord probably only two months back
i remember saying
stop telling me about all these leads
and these opportunities get me
some money right i'm not talking about
getting me money i'm saying
i want to see some money in your bank
get the money in the bank that was the
big thing we had a whole evening session
about it
and and and then you went and got some
money so since that call like
six weeks ago how much money have you
got in your bank right now
in the last six weeks profit eleven
thousand five hundred
eleven thousand five hundred and six
weeks guys give her a hand that is
incredible
incredible incredible um so you know
honestly
what advice would you give what's the i
mean i mean listen sometimes people
have been on the call a little while and
they haven't got that kind of results
um you know so some people have got some
results but not
that much that's pretty good going
in just six weeks what would you say
has been this the secret or the key to
getting that money um
a combination of training and networking
okay um you've got to make sure that
you train and you know exactly what
you're doing because
i didn't know what i was doing six
months ago i would never have been able
to do what i do now
um so training is always key
first the first hurdle you've you've
gotta make sure you go through that
um and secondly uh networking so
um i'm just basically repeating what
anthony said and that you really do need
to network with with everybody and
and start getting to know your clients
because
they're the ones that are after a
service and you've got to provide that
service
um you know and at the end of the day if
you help them then you're going to get
the return from that and
um and yeah i mean yesterday um
the deal that i sold didn't even go out
to my the rest of my investors because
i put up a relationship with an investor
and
i knew what he wanted i knew he was
ready to go and i jumped on the phone
straight away and said look
i've just been to view this property i
really think it fits your criteria
i think the the roi was 54
on a brr and i was like do you want to
go ahead with this
he was like yes definitely and i was
like okay well i'm gonna i want it to
come to you
first because i you know i've built up
that relationship he's already bought a
deal from me
and um he put money straight in my bank
like literally so you've got to really
um grow a relationship with with your
clients because you'll get that repeat
custom
so um yeah that's they're my few tips
anyway
i think training yes awesome you've done
all that you've done you've done the
training you've done the dlc masterclass
um networking absolutely you put
yourself out there all the time
you're always jumping up on these calls
you've been on every call i i think
even if you've been driving doing
viewings and stuff or you've been you've
been you've been negotiating you've been
you know you've still been on these
calls on wednesday nights which i really
respect
but i think thirdly i think you've
graphed it you know you've really worked
hard yeah this is so late at night
like before i was like
doing a full-time job stay-at-home mom
you know homeschooling and everything
and then my nights were literally
just all about this and it was so hard
work and
i totally appreciate that everybody's
probably in the same boat here
and i wanted to quit so many times
because you know it is hard work
you know we really work for our money as
deal sources but
it's that mountain you climb in you
you're climbing you're climbing you're
building a reputation
you know and as soon as you get to the
top honestly i've had
deal after deal after deal and you know
it's it's such a hard climb to start off
with but just don't quit
and keep going at it because you'll get
there eventually and then you know
i was going to quit my job anyway but
they let me
let me go and i was able to just uh 100
graft and you know from getting up in
the morning until late at night i'm
still
at it so that's brilliant well we're
definitely gonna do i think we've booked
actually um
i think is it march 25th or something i
don't remember the exact date but we're
meeting up you're coming around my house
me and again we're going to do a an
interview on winners on a wednesday
so she's coming on the show um which
which by the way is gonna massively
boost your brand up as well like
you know winners on a wednesday is
massively good for
for branding so it's just gonna be
amazing um
so gemma massive congratulations that's
absolutely incredible
um i wanted to also jump on there was a
there was a guy i was chatting with i
think he was just
yesterday um abby jeffrey we were
speaking yesterday
on one of the mentoring calls hey samuel
abbott how you doing bro
i'm good how are you yeah really well so
just just just
just pick up how did you get on with the
with the builder by the way
ah okay so uh just
just a bit of uh backstory um found a
property
uh a five bet property victorian house
which we thought could be converted into
uh four flats and there was reasonable
profit in it
it was a decent solid deal and
uh you know that there's around 388
thousand pound profit in it
it was a 1.5 million pound prof uh
property in southwest london
um but when we uh and the estate agent
told us there's a bit of refurb to be
done
uh so you know you guys can work around
that and then put up four flats
uh so when we went there i went there
with a builder
and when we went there the property was
absolutely immaculate
there was nothing wrong with the
property um
the owner kept it in absolute top-notch
shape and the structure of the property
that's why i think viewings are so
important
the struct the actual structure of the
property was slightly different
to the floor plan that we were given and
to make four flats the cost would have
just been too much because we would have
had to do a side extension
to put another set of stairs in and
unfortunately
the return on investment was just not
enough then so we had to pull out of the
possible uh possible deal um but
uh nevertheless uh it was um
it was it was a tough one to take
because you know it felt like a good
deal but
going there you learned a lot um from
speaking to a builder and everything
um but uh in in terms of uh
how i move forward i've actually been
speaking to my mortgage broker as well
and i thought you know i guess you guys
can probably try this out as well
i said to him you know you must have a
lot of investors coming to you
looking for properties and stuff so
would any of them be
willing to joint venture or you know
partner up with someone
uh for a return on their investment and
he said actually i've got quite a few
and uh you know we got we got talking
and he's willing to let me
uh come on to get access to his investor
list
and he is very keen to learn from me
about lease option agreements
so i have a zoom call with him tomorrow
um to teach him all about lease options
so
um one thing i've learned um really
quickly is that
you know training training is so
essential
uh you say work hard and doors will open
for you
but for you to be able to see those
doors in property you need to be trained
first and education is absolutely key i
think and that's what's happening now i
can just
see so many opportunities coming up um
and honestly as well i mean we've been
speaking obviously through the coaching
calls and stuff because
and again folks i know i say this every
week just to remind people especially if
you're new as well
or if you've just forgotten as part of
samuel 365
what abby what do you get you tell them
and let them hear it from you
oh it's just amazing um the mentoring
calls
just just book them just talk to
just talk to the guys no matter how
silly the question sounds
because you ask that silly question they
might tell you
an answer where other more important
questions might come up in your head
so just just book loads of mentoring
calls and just get on there because
you get out of that is unbelievable and
be that annoying person like it doesn't
matter i mean
like if you don't feel like oh you know
what i don't want to put anybody out
or i don't want to like be that person
that rings up and says look i'm stuck i
need help
um you know and then and then and then
um
come on here and and just really really
utilize your samuel 365 membership it's
95 pound a month
and we want you to get as absolute
maximum value as possible
i mean geez i mean if you look at other
other things around on the market you
want to get mentoring and training and
stuff
you you're not talking 95 pound a month
you're about to have access to anthony
david taylor
myself alex there any time unlimited you
know it's crazy value
and we want to make sure that you guys
are actually getting results and to get
results you do need the knowledge you do
need the information
and you do sometimes need a little bit
of a kick off the ass a reminder
um so book these calls eight o'clock
every wednesday [ __ ] them in even if
like gemma edens you're
you're out traveling on the road we can
see it you know
like driving and someone must be holding
a phone for her but you know so do that
so uh abby
awesome stuff what are you looking for
right now a bit and what can i do for
you
uh basically i've got quite a few
potential potentially really good
um deals in the pipeline
i've got about 10 properties that i'm
going to view uh
shortly uh hopefully within the next
with really good returns
um but obviously it's all subjective
viewing i have realized that now so
i won't put anything out before uh but
i'll put my details in the
uh in the chat if anyone wants to
connect uh please do
um and can i just say a massive thank
you to dave taylor
and tony crook and obviously yourself
who i've talked to this week and
it's been absolutely invaluable some
serious golden nuggets in there so
thank you thank you so much you're so
welcome great great job
um yeah again on that point i want to
shout out those two people as well i
mean we've shouted at anthony already
and heard from anthony
um tony corrup i don't know if tony's on
the call tony are you on the call
i've been with tony all day so he's
probably he's probably exhausted because
me and tony have been together all day
i know dave's on the call anyone that
doesn't know dave
structural engineer um also
very very specialist does architectural
work property developer
i mean dave's like a mentor to me i said
this on facebook the other day like dave
joined um
dave john the academy to to for me to be
his mentor but now it feels like it's
the other way around i'm always calling
him up
i'll be on i'll be on a development site
i'll be like hey dave i'm thinking of
building the house here
what do you reckon do you think it will
work and dave's giving me mentoring
we're really fortunate to have dave as
one of the samuel 365 mentors with his
with his knowledge and
background dave how did you get on in
jordan's house today dave
i don't know if david taylor's even even
listening like i've been picking him up
he didn't even smile
he didn't even smile david what's
happening can you can you hear me
hi hi how are you doing that's very good
were you listening to my big five minute
bigger bobby just now
yeah sorry yeah i was actually yeah but
i was just uh i was just uh
i just um just sold a deal so i just
got an email back oh wow brilliant
there we have it so congratulations how
much how much did you sell it for
two four nine five nice so so you got
you got a big big up from samuel leeds
and made two thousand five hundred
pounds all within
thirty seconds yeah sorry it's just it's
just an appropriate moment it just
literally came through and i'd
how did you get on at jordan's house
today yeah really good yeah
um we we're going to go back now we're
going to do a report we're going to go
back to the uh
to the vendor and try and get some money
off now so it's uh
didn't need to get the structural stuff
sorted yeah to get the structure sorted
the underpinning and things like that
but it was uh
how much strengthening you need to get
everything all done to get the structure
and stuff uh
just to get part of it done about 26k
but and then he's got
the refurb on top so okay the structural
stuff's about 26 so we should be able to
get that
reduced that's not too bad well dave all
right top piece of advice
um everyone on the call anyone call this
one
what about this top piece of advice for
someone that's looking to do the buy
refurbished refinance rent strategy how
do you find those deals
give me 30 seconds of wisdom
well the bar refurbished refinance ones
you you can basically go to the the most
expensive area
in your city and find the worst rundown
property you can
yeah and once you've found that one
that's when you can get the most value
because the the really the one that
needs the one you think you might think
that nobody else touched the floors are
all leaning
things like that because they're the
ones where you can get the most value
you can repair the building
if you imagine i have to build a whole
new house is like 90 grand
so if you can make 200 grand profit by
almost rebuilding the house it's a it's
a good deal that's
the type of thing you also on the
smaller properties
you look for the ones where you are or
unmodifiable
so you're going to catch purchases where
they they don't have any heating
and it says just a boiler that's not
working then you there's no
there's no stamp duty there's things
like that they're the type of things you
need to look at
so it's the worst property the most
expensive street
incredible man incorrect you know what
how privileged are we to just be on a
call
like this with all these experts in
property
you know just be able to accessible
dave's accessible dave's
one of the seven pc five mentors you can
book a holiday just book a call
one-on-one anthony tony crook
tony crookston 100 million with his
businesses guess what you can hop on a
call with him
have a 15-minute chat with him ask him
questions i'm one of the mentors i'm
jumping on calls now more and more
like you know really really great stuff
so david thanks man i appreciate you
being on you've been on the channel
i'm seeing so many reviews right now on
our trustpilot and google page
and and they're all crediting david
taylor david david david taylor i'm like
what an asset he is so
david you're an incredible you're
incredible at what you do so thank you
so much and um
samuel yeah thank you very much how's
patricia kelty getting on what's going
on with patricia
she's she's uh i see her and michael
both on the court
what's happening um well uh so
mike and i we have our first service
accommodation that we're finally going
to get the keys for on monday so
[Applause]
is that rent are you buying that sorry
a rent to rent are you buying it we're
buying
we bought this back in september before
we learned all of the wonderful
strategies so
um this one we're buying um and uh which
is really great because
we need that sort of regular income in
order to start qualifying for more stuff
in the future i'm this close to
finalizing my first joint venture for an
hmo as well
so yeah and
um yeah so we're just viewing properties
trying to package and co-source some
and doing all of our training and
staying connected with
the whole community and doing our liver
calls um we looked at a possible land
deal
as well so we might do something there
so
yes lots of really exciting things we're
just you know what you're interested
you and mike as a couple like i i i've
said this right from the very get-go
your success in property is not gonna be
it's not gonna be all hopeful it's it's
not gonna be possible
it's absolutely inevitable
right like it is it is but but here's
the thing
right you you're on the academy you
show up to every coaching call your
energy
even if you've had a shitty week and
things haven't worked out your energy
always
such a good energy you're you're so
helpful
you know you always implement what what
we teach i remember you were one of the
very first students i ever had
when we went into lockdown you were in
the lease option boot camp during like
april night time when i just created the
whole program
and you know it's just such an honor and
a privilege to have you in the community
so i'm
so glad to hear that you're getting some
success that you deserve i mean that
that service accommodation deal on
monday which is going to be completed
how much profit is that is that supposed
to be making you each month once you
complete on that property
well you know service accommodation is
such a tricky thing these days
especially because it's um
more focused towards tourism which is
always a little bit of a shaky thing to
talk about right now
but um i'm hoping based on a comparable
that's nearby
um the same size and we'll get it
renovated to look the same as well
um hoping to generate maybe 5k
a month hoping so i'll definitely report
back and let the team know
how it goes and and what my costs end up
being
and uh and what the roi ends up being
just wonderful people
have been helping every step of the way
so i'm so grateful to you and
the mentor team and the whole community
and my all of the friends that i've met
during this
time and it's just i feel really blessed
and we had to really i mean we spent a
lot of time with patricia even
like you know every mentor on the three
on the 365 and on the academy
has spent a lot of time with patricia
like one-on-one we've had to and i said
this to the guys because
because um i can't remember who it was
that was someone so it was like
we were having a meeting with the
mentors and it was like
we talked about you guys by the way you
know we do talk about you guys
and we were talking about like how much
it was not in a bad way but it was like
we all spent like an hour that day on
the phones and patricia
and and i remember saying you know what
i'm actually glad though because
patricia needs it right now she's got
so many deals and stuff she needs the
support right now and
the thing is with patricia as well like
if someone's booking loads and loads of
calls all the time
but they're not actually doing anything
then that's one thing but if someone's
booking lots of calls but they're taking
massive action in between calls
like i'll gladly sit on the phone with
you i'll gladly i mean
i can't wait to just have dinner with
you and mike and meet you guys again i
know we've met i think we met once in
person
and many many times um you know on zoom
and stuff so
massive congratulations and so good to
see so many people winning
on the call as as fabulous uh a guy who
i want to check in with
i just want to just check their okay
very very quiet
guy very very um smart
very knowledgeable but i just want to
hold him to account and that is someone
a founding member of 365
um i don't know how he's getting on and
he knows who he is already i bet he
knows come on
aaron matthau what's happening
hi what's good my friend
yes going it's just going okay uh
yeah i have to admit i haven't been um
as focused on property at the moment um
especially with the um uh cryptocurrency
markets
what they're doing at the moment so i've
been doing a lot of trading on
cryptocurrency
and not so much focus on property uh but
yeah i'm still on it
still um researching uh viewing
properties
and that sort of thing cool is there
anything you need from me
or the team to support you right now
because we really we really appreciate
you
you've been you've been on these calls
since day one and
and i want to make sure that you're
looked after i want to make sure that
you're loved i want to make sure that
you're taken care of as a customer
and also as a student as a friend so is
there anything we can do to support you
right now
um
i mean um
not really directly but if there's
anyone um
who's interested in joint venturing um
on uh
by refurbished refinance and do reach
out to me
um i've got funds for it um
i'm looking for someone who can like
sort of direct me a bit
on how to get started um you've got some
funds in place
you want to you want to do a brr deal
but you just necessarily haven't quite
got the time or whatever
so you're looking for a joint venture
partnership yeah
all right cool i'm sure you'll get some
messages off some of these folks and
that's aaron mathi
and aaron anything you need from me
personally any time buddy
um just give me a chat man thank you all
right appreciate you really do
i was with a guy today as well nice guy
cool guy his name is lamar love
and and lamar was telling me about how
um i'm gonna get him up in a second i
know demas on the call
mar was telling me about how a few weeks
ago every time he'd ring up about a rent
to rent and speak to an
estate agent they'd always be negative
they'd be cold
he wouldn't get anywhere um he recently
did the rent-to-rent accelerator and
he's beginning to now get some success
talking to agents so i thought it'd be
really good to just hear from the maybe
hear some tips
hear what's going on lamar are you still
on the call can you hear me
all right can you hear me yes yes hey
great to see you today we spent the
whole day together oh no
it's fantastic though it was a great day
my friend so
talk to me a little bit about um how to
get the best out of
estate agents and about kind of like
what's happening with you right now
yeah so like as i said today when i
didn't really know
what i was saying when um calling the
agents before i actually done the rent
to rent
um like i said i was getting a lot of
negativity
um pushed away really um decided to like
switch up my uh
area where i wanted to uh secure secure
some deals
um and now i've spoke to a few agents
and they're literally just emailing me
over deals ringing ringgit meal
um secured a couple of viewings
yesterday i've got a few more tomorrow
um meeting up with an investor as well
tomorrow so
he's got five properties got a bit of
equity in there he's looking to reinvest
so
it's looking it's looking good so far so
yeah like the more
i've done the training but the more
confident i've got no no the scripts
know what to say
and it's just going to plan really
that's so good lamar
so so what what do you need for me right
now to take things to a new level or
are you stuck in any way like what's
happening um
well right now i'm just literally
waiting on on the estate agent
to call to call the landlord to see if
they're willing to actually go ahead
with a rent to run um that's gonna be a
good news story next week man
yeah she didn't say that she would
actually put me in direct contact with
the landlord to be honest
so we'll see how that one goes but
right now um
but it's just waiting on the the estate
agent really just to see if the
landlord's willing to do it if not then
we just move on and just go again and
see who else is out there willing to do
and and and for anyone that's just
thinking like what the heck
how how was i with lamar today the mark
came down to beckonsfield we spent the
day together
uh well there was maybe like seven or
eight of us at the discovery day
and uh oh man it was a good day wasn't
it tomorrow yeah really good day
where are you from but you're back in
birmingham now i'm in worcester right
now and i'm in moscow right now
and we're starting so good so good man
hey great to see you buddy
is anyone stuck right now is anyone is
there
how are you doing man you're right yeah
great good good um
i'm new to property um i did crash
course a couple of weeks ago and i've
been
i've just been hammering your courses
and trying to look at hmos in grimsby
i'm from coventry
i'm kind of a cash buyer i've got about
100k to put into property at the minute
and i'm struggling to find a hmo at the
minute to put my money into
i've been off offered by someone um kind
of a
earn and learn kind of thing is he's an
investor he's got a hmo in coventry
and i put 50k in i'll get four percent
back after what six months but then
he'll teach me
everything i just don't know if that's a
good thing to go ahead with or just do
my own thing
kind of thing okay so i mean a couple of
things so you've got 50
did you say you got 50k how about 100k
you've got 100k
you're gonna put 50k in is he what
percentage he can take of the of the
profits
so um it won't be nothing to do with me
the deal that's what i'm trying to say
it's more but earn and learn i put 50k
in
and when he can take the money out he'll
give my give me my 50k back
with four percent what if it's two grand
it's nothing like but
then earn and learn kind of thing i
don't think that's the best option for
me
i mean it's not terrible basically the
guy's saying
you put the money in i'll give you
basically nothing
apart from knowledge so yeah it's not
bad i mean isn't it it's probably more
expensive
did you stay did you say you're on the
brl master class no i'm on most of your
courses i've done dfe i'm doing the uh
no money down deal i'm gonna do the hmo
whenever stuff i've got all them
probably little i mean the buy
refurbished finance masterclass is 995.
yeah yeah there's probably a little more
i mean listen you can't beat experience
exactly
yeah learn anything but you do the buy
refurbished refinance master class which
is 995
you're probably not going to learn
anything that new so
it's probably quite an expensive way to
just type some money and lose money on a
deal
for like 6-12 months that's that's what
i'm thinking not a bad offer
if i if i was the guy geez i'd look for
the same thing
yeah give me 50 grand and you can watch
over and learn from it but i'll give you
four percent back i mean i'm sure
there's i'm sure there's plenty
better opportunities than that um but i
would probably
pass i mean i don't know give me
give me a thumbs up and look down if you
wouldn't
most people are giving me a thumbs down
yeah yeah so
you know that's the general kind of
concept it's just the main thing me i
just want to learn and network i'll be
in networking i'm going in manchester to
see lauren friday i'm going grimsby
started 80 few properties monday i'm
going
back to coventry then thursday i'm going
back down to london's first
view properties dude i'm still working
i'm working now in london
anytime i'm doing i'm just moving around
just trying as much as possible
you don't need to give someone all your
money for them to just
teach you i don't think i wouldn't yes i
wouldn't do that
i would just keep doing what you're
doing keep networking
i would get on the buyer with service
you know reviews i think that's probably
what i would say uh is that helpful my
friend
yeah that's pretty helpful if anyone's
on here that wants to contact me or
anything that i'm knowledgeable just
contact me like i've got the funds
whether it's the jv or anything any
lodge you can give me is massively
appreciated
man that's awesome david anyone else
struggling or it's funny
the last two people that are struggling
a lot i've got the money i just haven't
i just need you know some people have
got the money some people have got the
time and deals um go on dinesh is
getting his money's worth today
go on um i'm similar in situation to
david because
i'm also i got some more 100k cash with
me
uh but the trouble is the initial
nervousness you know you're very careful
when you're a first time investor
so i need to get out of that hurdle um
to plunge into i'm doing the
brr master course as well as the hmo
master course and dsm
but again it's the same situation it's
it's a bit scared how to jump into it
because
there are too many unknowns yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and that's the thing and that's why i
think it's important to you know
the support that you have here not just
for me not just from the mentors but
from each other
you know is massive um so yeah
you you need to act with caution but at
the same time
don't be so cautious that you don't do
anything you know
uh peter turner wants to say something
go ahead peter oh hi everybody
first time in the in the coaching call
tonight
so nice to meet everyone um a bit of a
success story for you samuel
i uh i just finished my second brr deal
um i bought it in october 66
000. we spent 12 on it we're on 78
000 and we had the reval yesterday at
110.
oh my goodness so
i'm blaming you to be honest because
it's only really since
our family youtube and the training that
i've known anything about it i've just
been one of them clueless ones before
now
so uh that's awesome
and you've got a second deal as well you
say uh the first deal that i did was
um february 19 a boy 140 were
refurbished 25 and we rebuild it 200
that was the first time i did but since
i found your stuff i just chose cheaper
houses because making the same return
off the cheaper ones than i was
off the more expensive ones so yeah it's
working great
that's incredible buddy we need to
definitely hook up some time have we
have we've been speaking over social
media by the way
uh not not very much i've been talking
to tony quite a bit on the mentoring and
i've spoken to antony before but
i think i just need to kind of jack
things up a bit now i want to
i've been really enjoying my job so i
haven't wanted to jack my job in
but i feel like more and more now i want
to and i've got the funds and the
availability on deals to be able to do
it so
incredible with a bit of help on that on
the mentoring side
well that we're here for you that's
exactly what we're here for so peter
great job on that successful brr keep up
the good work and
need anything from myself or the team
give us a shout
cheers that's great awesome hi samuel um
hello
hello um i just have a question that
could just be like i just want to see
what people's experiences on it is
so basically um i have just started
doing sourcing for the last few weeks
and i'm working with a couple of uh code
use sources right now
yeah um and i have um
i've been in touch with a private of the
market landlord
in liverpool that's selling like 10 of
properties
in the kensington area um and i just
wonder if people who because obviously i
guess my thinking is that if i could
because
i know these are all really really good
deals and i think i can
um these will be good for like i'll be
able to make them into
actual good these deals to investors
um for these five of them and i just
wonder whether it like obviously if i'm
buying you know or
not buying about yeah i'm looking for
five or
ten of these properties and surely i'll
be able to say
um would you will you be able to give it
to me for slightly cheaper um if
i you know i'm getting all of them or
you know helping you sell all of them
but i don't know whether like how to do
so in like a
like a polaroid because obviously i
don't want to offend them especially
since they're
like off market seller and they just
wanna you know like the guy's retiring
and that's why he's
trying to get rid of his portfolio and i
just wonder if people have
an experience in you know in sharing uh
that they don't mind sharing and how
they would speak to an old marketer to
make
exactly so firstly have you got a deal
agreed
already or they just just told you what
he wants
um he just told me uh what he wants so
i'm seeing it on the weekend
uh my understanding is that he hasn't
shown it to any other investor he hasn't
really shown on any
he hasn't like no one's been in touch
with him at all so
um so so i would honestly uh is it a
cassia
acacia acacia i think we had this
occasion i would just say just like you
said to me i would just say listen it's
been on the market a little
i need to be out for a little while if
i'm to buy all of them
i don't want to offend you or come
across cheeky but if i'm going to buy
all of them at once
what what would be the what would be the
ball discount you could give me what's
the lowest you could accept
and still live with okay in cash all
right
and just that's it that's business
okay so it's not like i just don't want
to like come off as really rude or like
just say that as is it just say
look i don't want to come across rude or
anything but if i want to invite all of
them at once like
what's the ball discount you know you've
considered what's the lowest you'd be
able
to accept for the whole bunch okay and
then zip it and wait for him to give you
a figure and you might be very surprised
okay that sounds that sounds like a good
idea when i do that
um and if uh yeah i've been speaking to
drama about this
actually um she's been giving me some
advice on um
uh on you know how to uh do the how to
do this whole new sourcing thing but if
anyone else
um might be interested in these 10
potentially html
properties then please drop me a message
all right good stuff
great job thanks samuel oh hold on one
second i'm gonna take two i
said two more and then i need to jump on
with david all right so we've only got a
few more minutes
so um i think richard hawkes has been
richard
and then who's the lady just now as well
who was the
uh who just spoke up
who said hi samuel yeah it's richard hi
mate how are you doing
but there was a lady's voice that said
hi samuel
maybe maybe richard maybe you just it
might have been a high-pitched version
of me i don't know but um
if i cut a lady off just now i'm so
sorry
um richard go ahead what's your question
cool man so um yeah just wanted to say
hi i'm
looking for deals at the moment i've
been researching areas up north
liverpool
looking around birkenhead things like
that um
the i came across that this week i
thought it'd be interesting i kind of
know
my opinion of it but i'd be interested
to get a take and it might be good for
the group but i spoke to an agent today
um and it's a tenanted property so it's
a landlord selling out a tenanted
property
um you know and i'm kind of talking
about
missions reviewing it anyway because
they're not happy about the virus what
not but
when asked about getting it vacant
possession yeah the agents kind of
saying well
no they're not you know obviously at the
moment it's
difficult long nearly impossible to
evict tenants
um you know and so she's talking about
a sale with with tenants in situ which
it doesn't fit for me
um you know it blows the numbers apart
having to have a tenant there for
six or twelve months while we go through
the process so
it's it's a pass for me but i'll just be
interested in yours or anyone's views
you know given i want to refurb it right
i want to go and raise the value i want
to go and
you know get it up to scratch refinance
it yeah yeah
that's it all right first thing is this
is that it's not unusual to ask to buy a
house
vacant that's a very reasonable request
so you're not being weird or cheeky or
strange asking for that
second thing is it is possible to get
rid of tenants
i mean yes it might there might be
certain things going on at the moment
which
give the tenants um extra protection
because of the
the situation that we're in you know
economically and everything which is
totally fair enough and reasonable
yeah maybe i'll do a talk like next week
i just got rid of a load of tenants
i had some properties i had some tenants
i wanted to have to rejig and do some
things
and i had to get rid of some tenants now
how did i do it i i just bribed them a
little bit
i was like look look folks i don't want
you in my house anymore man
i really want you gone i get that you
need to find somewhere new and this that
the other
so look how about this get out
by the first of march and i'll give you
a thousand quid
each is a hmo i'll give you a thousand
quid each and they
and they all moved yeah so yeah it cost
me
cost me four grand but i made a lot more
than that because of what i was trying
so i think you know it's not
unreasonable if they're refusing to get
rid of the tenants and they're saying no
either say all right well in that case
if he's going to take ages to get rid of
the tenants then
it's going to be a long sale then i'll
buy it when it turns her out or walk
away
but it's not unreasonable so that's
probably my general thoughts richard on
that
yeah i think it's spot on actually it's
yeah there's a way i mean yeah the best
way to get them out
either yeah find them somewhere else to
live right um exactly yeah
exactly i'll move them into a house down
the road which is my house
yeah if i'm not personal i'm just like i
need to get you out this house
so yeah all right thanks so much for
that richard needed to give a little
shout out
a couple people why don't you give a
shout out of course to mark parham
mark parham is doing super good things
in fact we probably should get mark on
my youtube channel at some point
apparently mark's
did have you done that video or were you
are you gonna do that video
i've done it i've done it it's out
that's it
you know samuel lee's exposed video he
click-baited me
oh no
[Laughter]
oh man i'm used to it now it's not a
[ __ ]
not a plot a person now you know i don't
mind you
you can click honestly folks if you want
to clickbait just like do you want to
click back me for your youtube channel
you want to put me in the title and say
stuff
i really don't give a monkeys like you
know and i'm sure mark didn't say
i've not watched the video yet but i'm
sure he didn't say anything bad in the
video i'm sure it's just a clickbait
title
not at all and can i also just shout out
to lawton i had a great conversation
with lawton last week
after the samuel 365. i facetimed him
had a really good chat with him
um and you know i just wanted to give
him a shout out and say
that's awesome man that's awesome lauren
was one of the people thanks so much
mark
um lauren was one of the people i wanted
to give a shout out as well too lawrence
lawton's doing incredible things lauren
how's your week on
hey what's going on guys yeah my week's
been pretty jam-packed to be fair
i've had so many viewings going on we've
found some new potential land
development sites
you know commercial two commercial units
four flats above it it's it's going
pretty crazy to be fair and obviously
with the ff challenge i mean
just drop a little comment in it below
if you've seen it and let me know what
you thought but like
since the ff challenge i've been like
flooded with messages and i've been
overwhelmed with the positive comments
so just thank you
thank you so much from the bottom of my
heart for all those so much appreciate
it guys thank you oh good job man
good job man um i wanted to give a shout
out to george lao
george is on the academy hannah kassonga
she's also newly on the academy uh jamal
campbell as well i keep seeing him pop
up on social media jamal what's
happening buddy
where'd you come out hey samuel when and
what is your next deal that's what i
want to know we're gonna
the 161 people on this call right now
are going to hold you to account
look i'm looking to try getting next
deal in the next couple weeks samuel
i've been viewing properties like crazy
today i had a lot of i looked at a lot
of orcs and probably the past couple
days
so um yeah it's um it's really exciting
all right so so we want to see something
in the bag
by this but by the 24th of february
all right all right all right all right
what's up as well
i can't not give a shout out to this
dude you may remember last week
we had david nicole responsible david
eckles
so david what's happening
yes i've got wi-fi this week oh that's
good
dude the wi-fi your place is miserable
the weather was miserable the wi-fi was
miserable
my knowledge of the area was miserable
your money in the bank was miserable but
we had an
absolutely phenomenal week last week
doing the financial freedom challenge
with uh with david
i don't want to give away too much but
how did it go david
oh absolutely brian samuel because it
was the best week of my life basically
at the non-top market so we didn't know
if the strategy was going to work so
samuel says
just go under agents but i don't want to
give too much away but the first agent
we went into
they were just handing all states so
easy and
i was in shock basically
and we were like we're looking to do um
a corporate let where we can give a
guaranteed win and they were like oh
that sounds really good
we've not heard of that before come and
sit down and have a cup of tea to be
sure
we walked out with a frigging leader
he then goes and does at least after
social media it's like
killing it
the leash option can i tell them about
that
don't give them the specifics but go on
i'll not tell you too much but basically
it was the best leash option you could
ever get it was in ireland so we're
doing both we're doing ireland and
northern ireland and
isis to samuel well the least option
work in ireland he says of course it
would and i was like
i don't think it will the second phone
call i made that girly shops and
i won't give the details away but it was
the best ever lease option agreement
that you could absolutely get so thank
you to um
um yes yes i know dinesh has done
business i hope that works
out also did i see your your son in the
background is
is he is he around yeah hey what is
happening buddy how are you doing
how are you amazing are you learning how
to be a property
investor at such a young age oh
good to see you buddy we're going to
meet one day you're going to come around
the house for some dinner
hurry or something um also as well um
as well lynette as well lynette thank
you for your support i hope that
this works out you can keep us posted um
so
so
david what was the biggest takeaway from
you well obviously at some point we'll
do a full-on q a
it's not even dropped yet it's going to
be dropping next month but what's going
to be the
what's going to be the what was the
biggest takeaway for you during the week
uh i'll be honest samuel it was as about
to persistence now i'll give you an
example that agent
we walked into you know was very open to
the deal
yeah sitting in cambridge today at nine
o'clock
i got a phone call at 10 o'clock to say
david i've got an off market deal
have you come look at it tomorrow you
can have it and i'm actually now in
ireland so
i got on a flight basically four hours
later
and that's all down to you saying about
be persistent
take the action and the results so you
have to be persistent do the training
and the results do definitely come if
you put yourself in that environment
it's going to be the most amazing
documentary man so david
massive it was unlike anything that's
ever happened
um and also the whole you know like
lawton's documentary in evans
documentary they're quite emotional at
the end
and all that um yeah david's is
different
david's fine a little different
anything else but david great job man oh
my god i hope to see you here next week
um so so folks what an absolute pleasure
graziella mintron is also here it looks
like she's an are you on an airplane
graziella or you start a train
grazie it looks like she's on an
airplane or something she's
off oh no she's going to she's going to
go oh man she's on a train
she's on a train yeah all right awesome
stuff
so folks thank you so much for a great
evening
i hope this has given injected you with
some energy
i hope you've seen some useful contacts
i hope that you've been um
inspired learned a couple things
graziella's now
the delay now has picked up so she's now
she's now she's now here graziella
you're incredible i'm looking forward to
seeing you soon
i am expecting a baby on monday so
that's going to be incredible
um so by the time i by the time i next
see you guys on this call
i'll probably be a father of three god
willing it's a plan c section so um you
know we're really really really excited
about it thank you so much guys
um listen as well i just want to say i
know some of you i know i say this every
single week and i'll say it unashamedly
but if you are a customer which you all
are and you
haven't ever taken a moment to leave us
a review
honest review whether it be good or bad
as long as you be genuine
please please please do go down to
trustpilot
or google or both and just take a minute
to leave a review abby jeffrey thank you
for your kind review
a couple days ago i really appreciate
that so if
if you've um enjoyed being a samuel 365
member tell the world
shine the light i mean just imagine
there's 159 people on the court right
now
imagine if everybody just took uh 60
seconds to leave a review on google or
oral it would just be massive
you know for me for the business so
please do take a moment to get tonight
give me a thumbs up if you're gonna do
it
i really appreciate it if you've already
done this reviews before then that's
fine
but if you haven't done a review yet
please go ahead and do that
um if you get stuck in the week book a
mentoring call
we'll be back same time next week thank
you so much for being on the court if i
didn't get to answer your question i'm
sorry
book a call and we'll draw one-on-one so
folks
thank you so much thank you for
everything you bring and good night
thank you
[Music]
you